uh a little bit of breaking news uh
reaching us as to uh
the state of the health of the duke of
edinburgh buckingham palace releasing
uh the following statement uh some good
news the duke of edinburgh yesterday
underwent a
successful procedure for a pre-existing
heart condition
at st bartholomew's hospital his royal
highness will remain
in hospital for treatment rest
and recuperation for a number of days
let's speak now to our royal
correspondent at rhiannon mills and
rhiannon uh some some good news about
the duke of edinburgh
that's right so it was on monday that we
were
surprised i'd say uh to see that the
duke of edinburgh was being
moved from the king edward the seventh
hospital where he'd been for almost two
weeks we knew that he was being treated
for an infection
but it was decided by doctors that he
needed to be moved to
some bartholomew's hospital we were told
that he would
continue having treatment there for that
infection he would be continued to be
tested
observed but also they would be looking
into this pre-existing
heart condition that the duke of
edinburgh also has
now it has to be said that over the
recent years we haven't actually
heard anything about him having any
problems with his heart
but you might remember that it was back
in 2011
that he did have some problems with a
blocked artery which meant that he was
taken to
papworth hospital in cambridgeshire
where he was then
fitted with a coronary stent but
certainly since then
in terms of any other health issues that
we've heard with the duke of edinburgh
it has tended to be
around urinary tract infection which i
think most of us
sort of suspected that that's why he'd
been taken to the king edward vii but i
think it's worth us reading over that
statement again that we've literally had
in the last few moments
um from the palace in which they have
confirmed that he underwent a successful
procedure
i understand that that we can call that
surgery
for a pre-existing heart condition at st
bart's hospital
they also say that he's going to remain
in that hospital for treatment
rest and recuperation for a number
of days that was quite interesting i was
speaking to a cardiologist
um earlier in the week who was
explaining to me that actually when
someone of that age
yes of course we're going to be
concerned about the fact that he was
transferred to
another hospital an nhs hospital which
has all of that set up for
potential emergency care but actually
what he was saying is that
often he in the past has treated elderly
patients who when they've had an
infection whether it's a urine infection
whether it's chest infection sometimes
that can
exacerbate other underlying conditions
and that's what he's suspected yes it's
difficult to diagnose without all of the
facts but that's what he expected may
have happened with the duke of edinburgh
he went into hospital with an infection
it may well have exacerbated
the heart condition that he's had also
though however the cardiologist was
saying that
in some ways the fact that the duke is
99 years old he's due to turn 100
later on in the summer his doctors would
not want to put him through
any procedures tests that may well cause
him
more hurt more concern and more pain
so in some ways we should potentially
look at this as good news that the duke
veteran has had that successful
procedure
but yes as you would anticipate after
any surgery he is going to remain in
hospital for a few days